Get ready with me for our baby's gender reveal.
I am 10 weeks pregnant with our first child,
and we are so excited to find out who this little one is.
We decided to do the early blood test
instead of waiting for an ultrasound.
This first trimester has had me for a loop.
I have been so nauseous and stuck on the couch for the past two months,
hence why my hair is so greasy.
It hasn't been washed in a week,
and it is so gross. I know,
but I have a heart condition called POTS,
and that plus the nausea makes showering such a chore.
It's, like the only activity I can do all day.
So we are working with the greasy hair
and hiding it with braids in a scarf for the gender reveal.
I did the blood test last week,
and the lab sent the results to my mom.
She mailed us a couple of color blasters,
and that is how we are going to find out.
My whole family is watching over video chat
because they're long distance,
and I'm just so happy they get to be included despite the distance.
This is the first grandbaby and great grandbaby in my family,
and I just know our little one is gonna be so loved.
Come back tomorrow to find out if we're having a boy or a girl,
and let me know in the comments what you think.